[موسيقى]
في اعمال كبيره انه تنحل مشاكل كتير ضخمه
بالحياه صرنا صعب كتير الوصول الها بسبب
تعقيد هاي الامور الوصول الى بدون مساعده
الذكاء الصناعي في تطبيقات راح تدخل على
المجال الصحي تشخيص الامراض باختراع ادويه
جديده
بطرق تعليم جديده
حتى باماكن بالمجتمع يمكن لم يكن يعتقد ان
الذكاء اصطناعي راح يشارك فيها مثل جوانب
فنيه بالتاليف الموسيقى كتابه قصص وروايات
حتى كتابه شعر
جوده القرارات والتحليلات تبع الذكاء
الصنعي هي بجوده المعلومات اللي بيتدرب
عليها
فمن المهم جدا انه الداتا المعلومات مثل
ما وقت الانسان يتدرب على معلومات منحازه
او خاطئه راح يوصل لافكار وطريقه تفكير
وطريقه اتخاذ قرارات خاطئه لاحظ نفس الشيء
راح يصير الزكاه الصناعي فمن المهم جدا
مسؤوليه كتير كبيره على الشركات
انه تتاكد من نوعيه وجوده
اللي ذكاء الصناعي عم يتدرب عليها مشان
تامين
تخفيض اي تاثير سلبي راح يكون على المجتمع
[موسيقى]
وفي حوار دائم بين المختصين والحكومات
بالوقت الحالي
للتطوير طريقه لاتخاذ القرارات هاي
والحدود من الاخطار السلبيه للذكاء
بس بالنهايه الهدف هو انه دائما يكون
عندما يتخذ الثقه اصلا اقرار خاطئ يكون في
جهه معروفه واضحه هي تحمل كل المسؤوليه
لهذا القرار
[موسيقى]